hi I'm Eric Lawson adventures infinity
war left one question unanswered that
until now I feel like few of us
what exactly was Loki's plan at the
beginning of this movie well whatever
the plan was it obviously didn't work
specifically back when Loki stole the
tesseract from Odin's vault at the end
of thor ragnarok I feel like the assumed
reason at least in my head was to use
that tesseract to strike a deal with
Thanos and maybe repay his debt for
blowing it in the first Avengers so when
Thanos his sanctuary ship dropped in on
them and the Ragnarok post-credits scene
just kind of made sense that Loki would
have been the one to make that call
essentially betraying his brother and
his people that made it definitely a
twist when he pulled out the rug from
Thanos and Infinity Ward throwing a Hulk
at him and trying to stab him in the
face
damn this god of mischief you can never
quite get a read on what's running
through that head until nothing is
running through it look that mysterious
quality to Loki compared to the other
Marvel characters at least has
definitely inspired a lot of conspiracy
theories but this video lets rewatch
Loki at the end of Ragnarok and the
beginning of infinity work analyze some
new recent statements by the filmmakers
and some recently released test footage
of Thanos I want to see if we can arrive
at a legit explanation of Loki's
strategy and tactics moments a moment I
want to start with what the directors
and screenwriters have said about Loki
and Infinity Ward the Russo brothers
confirm that Loki's actions in this
movie are true in genuine not part of
any trickery there's another character
who began his journey as a villain and I
think finally shows his true colors an
infinity war when he makes an attempt to
murder Tanis to save his own brother to
tragic consequences yes
tragic consequences he's dead yeah this
guy's is The Hulk
he ain't Lukie shape debris floating
outside the sound effect was pretty
telling guys there was also recently
released test footage of Josh Brolin as
an early animated version of Thanos
that was shown to Marvel execs early in
the production process with dialogue
that was not in the script but it
suggested that Loki's death was always
going to be part of this story
the fact is Loki you and I
not the sword people understand sore
people fear now I got the information
that I needed now I have to break your
neck
but just because Loki's actions were
sincere doesn't mean that they weren't
orchestrated the screenwriters were
asked why Loki so dramatically delayed
that the reveal of Hulk when one might
assume Hulk might have been more useful
earlier in this battle and here's how
they responded there's also a plan on
their part you know I think they were
getting Thanos into position and then
giving him the best chance did
yeah-ha-ha plan so what exactly was this
plan and how far back to the plan go
let's rewind back to the final act of
thor ragnarok
as Loki goes to throw Searchers skull on
the flame and Odin's vaults he stops to
look at the tesseract containing the
space stone of course and a look of
opportunity fills his face despite his
reputation as the god of mischief I just
don't think that Loki was thinking far
enough ahead about his infinity war
Thanos plan in this moment in fact you
could argue that Loki taking the
tesseract here is pretty suicidal for
him considering it's precisely what
draws they a no sin the black order to
him if he had just left it where it was
the tesseract would have been lost in
the debris of the ruins of asgaard after
searcher destroyed it floating out there
in space a rogue shadow waiting to be
described as Loki shaped by some
creative conspiracy theory fans famous
would have found the tesseract
eventually but at least in that scenario
Thor Loki Heimdall and the poor as
Guardians wouldn't have been in his way
clearly Loki did not intend to run into
Thanos his shock at seeing the sanctuary
ship in the Ragnarok post-credit scene
seemed very genuine so why did Loki take
the tesseract then well put yourself in
Loki's shoes the tesseract is the golden
egg that has eluded him for years
vanna's are know Thanos this thing has
real value to Loki and since he was
headed back to earth a place that hates
him and filled with Avengers with all
kinds of painful powers it wouldn't hurt
him to have an infinity stone as a check
against any threat that comes his way
but let's get back to Loki's plan the
plan that we see infinity war begins off
screen
technically between the end of Ragnarok
at the beginning of infinity war as
Stannis's attack on the Asgardians began
presumably as the Asgardian ship began
to quake Loki met with Thor and Heimdall
and Hulk and probably also Valkyrie Korg
and meek as well to figure out the best
possible way to hold Thanos off
presumably that plan could have included
Valkyrie Korg and meek to lead a small
escaped crew away from the chaos we'll
probably learn more about that in
Avengers 4 but for those who stay behind
Loki must have known that Thanos and his
children and his army are super powerful
so if they're gonna get out of live they
have to use every tool at their disposal
and then includes the element of
surprise so first off Thanos the
tesseract but wait until you would be
properly motivated by seeing your
brother in pain even though I'm sure
part of Loki enjoyed watching that and
then right as Thanos reaches for the
bait surprise them with a trap we have
and you know especially when this plan
was probably rushed it's not the worst
strategy to demigods and a Hulk against
the mad Titan yeah I mean that was
enough to hold off hella a couple days
before so all they needed to do was hold
off Thanos long enough to lower Thanos
his guard and get him within reach of
Loki's sneaky dagger and remembered that
dagger was forged from the same over
metal that all Asgardian weapons are
made from including the linear and storm
breaker which as we saw later in the
movie it's definitely powerful enough to
break through thinnest his skin and how
Loki unlike his idiot brother was
definitely smart enough to at least go
for the head problem is Loki just
underestimated how strong Thanos and his
forces were and there was no way for him
to know that Thanos had just recently
sacked Xander to get that power stone
and then have said to infinity stones
where the time he killed Loki so
unfortunately the odds were just not and
Loki's favor aah now I should say that
it's also possible that Loki knew taking
the tesseract could place a target on
his back for the mad Titan to come find
him but maybe he would prefer it stay in
seifish Asgardian hands that would make
Diana's have to fight for it but I think
Loki values his neck a bit more than
that
Loki probably only showed his true
colors of noble sacrifice once Fanus
found him and their situation became
desperate but with that here's my
question for you guys do you think
Loki's plan was smart all things
considered comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and ei vas for some
interesting funny stuff that I'm working
on that I think you guys will like and
speaking of like do that to this video
and subscribe Denis rockstars because if
there's a question to be asked about
Loki ya know we're gonna ask it even if
we have to break our necks over it oh
we're gonna we're not gonna do it this
time
I just feel like it was the perfect
setup for thank you